I class my favorite classes on
communicating data and statistics it's
everybody's favorite class who takes it
I think there's some selection bias
though because maybe only 40 people will
show up to the class even even though
there are thousands of people like at
Columbia who should take it but there's
more selection bias because out of 40
maybe I'll end up with 15 and and
they're great those those 15 people and
what one thing I tell them is that is
that like everyone who's a statistician
is a teacher so I teach people we're
teaching how to communicate how to teach
you all know the most important person
you need to communicate with yourself
who it with is you're yourself six
months ago and she doesn't answer emails
we're all teachers so I think you all
like this is not a roomful of professors
but I think anyone who's worked in any
kind of data analytic capacity will
recognize that that might even be most
of your job is to explain what you're
doing to other people to teach people to
reassure people to tell them no I'm not
going to jump all over you what you're
doing is okay I'm so forth and it's
funny because teaching it's it's just my
job it's nothing I've ever been trained
to do at all which is probably true for
all of you now when I I learned a lot as
a student my first semester in graduate
school I was a teaching assistants for
Fred Mosteller
who had been teaching introductory
statistics at Harvard for 30 years and
had written many books he took us to
lunch every week and I remember once he
asked us our opinion on some I can't
remember some education thing like what
should be done blah blah blah we'd give
our opinions and then he just snapped
right back eyes he said that's not what
you should do and said what do you mean
and he said when somebody asks you what
you think it's not because they care
what your opinion is they're asking you
as a statistician so you should answer
by suggesting how you would
design a survey or an experiment to
study it that's why they're asking you
well maybe we could say more things like
maybe you could design a measurement
error model or whatever but that the
same principle now the other thing he
told us was that you never know what
people are gonna get out of your class
so he he said he would teach different
things in different years and it
sometimes like he would run into a
student years later and it turns out
they didn't get anything out of his
class except one throwaway remark and it
changed their life so you don't know
what it's gonna be so when I teach I
always say I need a take-home message in
every class every class like what are we
going to do today this is what we're
doing today and you're gonna get
something out of it and come home with
this message and so I thought I have to
do that for you I am you can you pay
Jared your hard earned money to hear
this you're not here just to be
entertained you want to hear to learn
something useful so what could it be
well like our tips maybe not you all
know more about our than I do there
there's a graph here I guess I can draw
it here um so the x-axis is is what's
the x-axis
what's the x-axis always time right
right the x-axis is time the the y-axis
is like how good you are and then it's
like how good you are at our and here I
am gradually improve well I started
using s but same idea so I gradually I
gradually improved now here you are
I've been improving right here you are
who started 20 or 30 years after me and
you up here right so for me to say hey
look what I learned just now this is
stuff like heathered a new trick in base
graphics you want to hear it
I mean what do you what next you want
what do you want like space invaders
cheat code so it's it's right not can
happen so I can't do that well I could
tell you about Stan but I think maybe
that's too wonderful to waste on you
right now
maybe maybe next year at you Aaron if
you invite me back so so here it is I'll
tell you something that you can take
home you can take to the bank and
succeed with it um it's it's this thing
it's you might not have heard of its
called p-values and what you do is you
you run an experiment now it's kind of
important that you do an actual
randomized experiment or a random sample
survey something with probability in it
because there's a well-known principle
and applied statistics that a chain is
as strong as its strongest link so right
you say yeah exactly you have to think
that one through then you laughs I write
ten it's not really true that the train
but it's just how people act so the idea
is you need that you need that
identification that's your key to the
kingdom and then once you're once you're
inside the castle you can ransack the
place right so run an experiment okay
then you have a pile of results so for
every result you have calculated p-value
if it's less than 0.05 you found
something real you've made a discovery
and if it's more than 0.05 then you've
proved that something is zero and
so either way there's a win but you can
get a little bit more out of this I this
another little trick you can do which is
if it's if the p-value is are like
between 0.05 and 0.1 you can say that
you've discovered that it's a small
effect and then you can get entire
patterns out of this
now you might worry if you do that this
you might worry that your measurements
might be too noisy that these these
things might not replicate but don't
worry okay don't worry because what do
we care about we care about two things
in life right - only two things in life
for realz bias and variance right so but
but I mean that I mean that like I mean
I don't necessarily mean it the way
people always mean it but I mean it now
you don't have any bias because you
remember you did a randomized experiment
so therefore you have no bias you also
have variance well you're the problem
with variances if it's too big but why
is it a problem with variance is too big
because that means your power will be
too low why is it a problem that your
power is too low that you won't get
statistically statistical significance
luckily if you follow my advice and
you've looked at enough things that
you've resound statistical significance
therefore retro actively your power was
just fine right this is you know this is
this is what we're gonna say like in a
couple weeks right you know the Warriors
didn't need Kevin Durant you know
they'll or whatever it is right okay
though the power is is just fine so
therefore your measurements were good
enough so you don't have to worry about
that okay now you maybe think I'm
speaking ironically
and you might say this white work in
academia because the goal of academia is
to publish a paper okay so it's it's a
little like academia is like sports
right you want to win the game once you
got the W and that one more in the W
column the game is over it doesn't
matter if you deflated the football
whatever it is right I'm sorry about
that just that Jared told me I had to
mix in sports analogies because he he
was because I Jared gave me this whole
pep talk beforehand like about how to
speak for this audience and he was
saying like Sports is true its
statistics is traditionally full of
sports analogies and he was thinking
though like it's really become a little
too soft a little bit too touchy-feely
you know and so Jared's like reintroduce
the bro element into your talking I said
like Jared like if that's what you want
I think I am not the right speaker for
you but whatever
so I'm trying my best to to throw these
things in a will so the point being
though is that like in in academia it's
like you just want it when the each once
you win the game it's over in you know
in real life like you all mostly work in
in in the real world right whatever that
means and there it's more like a game of
ping pong like you want to keep scoring
points and I don't ping pong John I
don't know it looked better in the
slides he wouldn't let me use slides
either that was another thing so okay so
so you might it's a little different
because your goal like in in business is
to make money maybe you're not all
business your goal in government is to
help people out help often it's to help
people use the services available to
them and nonprofits you might be working
in medicine you really want to change
things for the better it's not just
ratcheting up winds it's not just about
having a fancy CV it's it's about things
that are going to count to somebody to
real stakeholders
um but it actually this trick I told you
about the statistical significance it
kind of still works in the real world
and I've seen that like I've talked to
people like they're doing a/b testing
and they're like yeah we we set the
threshold down to 0.8 instead of 0.9
five because we wanted to get this like
people are you can use these tools to
succeed on the it's kind of cool because
it's like alchemy you've you've like
converted randomness into certainty and
but there's there's a principle we
sometimes call it the conservation of
variance which is that the variance has
to appear somewhere else right so the
flipside of taking something certain
uncertain and pretending it's certain is
that it will fail to replicate later
right it's like the variance has to go
somewhere and that's why you could say a
lot of statistics is like a pyramid
scheme and like you really want to get
in on the ground floor which I've never
really understood that because in the
pyramid you want to be on the top
because the ground floor is where all
those suckers are but they built that
build the pyramid starting from the
bottom so I don't really understand the
pyramid scheme principle it seems to be
at just a terrible analogy and okay um
so how can we understand this there
there is a tool that we can use there's
a set of tools like you could use Python
whatever but I'll say are because it's
the are conference I spoke at the pines
conference the Python conference at like
a year or two ago and I told them I
didn't to have any Python so like is
that okay and they're like sure it's
just called the Python conference it's
not really so I think this is probably
similar I'm
so how do we understand this what we
have to do is is we have to simulate the
world and I I'm serious about this so if
I want to I mean it this is kind of old
school like you'd say oh yeah some thick
headed person doesn't understand the
Monty Hall problem so let's do a
simulation like who cares about the
material I'll like the Monty Hall
problem actually because I feel like it
sends the message that probability is so
tricky by giving it's not really that
tricky you can kind of brute force
things but if you wouldn't understand
something like what happens if you call
things statistically significant and
then act as they're true and then two
replications what you want to do is is
simulate a world in which people behave
in a certain way and then see what
happens and you can see what happens so
if you're working in your company doing
a/b testing and you want to use an 80%
threshold or whatever the answer is not
80% like to say that the answer is 80% I
mean that would be like saying like like
I'm a biologist and I want to grow a
colony of like amoebas and I give them
like a certain amount I give them like a
you know two grams of amoeba food a day
and and you know like the answer they're
like I said then the questions like how
many amoebas are there in three days the
answer is not two grams of amoeba fee
that's the input right so similarly if
you want to know how reliable are your
inferences of you do significance
testing within eighty percent threshold
the answer is not eighty percent eighty
percent is the equivalent of two grams
of amoeba food a day that's the input
right the only way you're going to know
the output is to run the simulation so
you can do that now it turns out running
a simulation is hard so it's a lot
harder it's a lot easier to analyze data
than to simulate fake data and even in
in statistics there's this funny thing
they talk about the likelihood the
likelihood is drivable from the data
distribution but the data distribution
is more complicated than the likelihood
more one likelihood could map too many
data distributions so it's actually it's
easier to do Bayesian inference or just
about anything else than to simulate
fake data but only by simulating fake
data
or obviously sometimes you can do it
through math but that's rare right so
only only through simulating like
laughing and I wasn't a joke like I got
you I got you all on the edge here I
could say anything at this point
so no like so to simulate the fact that
you have to simulate a system what does
that mean if you're doing your AP
testing or or you know whatever you're
doing you're working for the government
and you're trying to improve you know
people's use of social services or
whatever your you're aiming for um you
have to have a model for the world so
you have to say if I'm doing the a/b
testing well how big is the affected I'm
testing okay
well what's going to happen statistics
is said to be the science of defaults
okay so the difference between say it's
destitution and I don't know like there
are physicists who work in probability
and what they'll do is spend ten years
working on one problem a really hard
problem building a lot of scaffolding I
mean they're they're building the
Chrysler Building as it were like that's
and that's a career statisticians were
more like like the guy who made
Levittown like except without the racial
exclusion and all that where we just
built we want to build a lot of tract
houses you know that that's kind of how
we think ok so you have to imagine
someone is going to do this procedure
what was it solve all your statistics
problems using p-values I think that was
that you know that Jared gave me that
title and said go from there so this is
really all just up to his fault um so
he's like you can't get out of this way
yes I can't get out right I tell you
this time you can't trap me so you need
it's not just ok how big is this
affected I'm study you need to have a
hypothesis about that and that's all
this is really hard what's my prior for
the effect I don't know if I had a good
prayer for the effect I wouldn't need to
do the dam a be test and in the first
place you fool like you can't think of
it that way
ok the prior is real ok the prior is
it's real I'm like one of those you know
holy rollers you know like like I feel
oh god you know whatever I feel the
prior it means something it's the
distribution it's a distribution of
actual effect so you have to say like
okay all of statistics is about
repetition it's about the frequency
we're all frequentist here okay so the
idea no real really um so the ideas
there is a stream of problems you're
working on you didn't get hired to do
one a B test there's not one program
you're rolling out there's not one drug
you're testing there's a stream of these
things now in a usual talk I would start
saying okay what's our prior for this
how do you validate this a lot of
interesting stuff like all our research
everything we do like when we're not
doing all the other stuff that we're
doing and when you but of here I'm
framing it another way I'm talking about
how I want to help you right so you are
creating you're writing an art program a
simulation a little part of that little
function in in there little you know
little thing is how you're gonna analyze
the data but the hard part's creating
the data so you have a stream of
problems coming in model that it's not
one problem okay it's not whatever it
said two grams of amoeba fee today right
it's you have a stream of problems how
large are these effects to what extent
are the effect sizes gradually going
down you've got to model that now you
put that in it could be wrong that's
fine then you go back and change it but
you got to make some assumptions about
that how faster decisions coming in when
you make a decision how long does it
persist before you're going to redo it
anyway what are the costs you kind of
work it through then you say here's here
a bunch of strategies I'm gonna follow
the 80% strategy the 95% strategy the
Bayesian strategy whatever okay well the
way the Bayesian strategy works is it's
optimal if the assumptions are
correcting you average over the prior
distribution of course you don't know
that so then you'd have to try other
models that that's fine but you need to
you do that then you'll find out what
will happen if you follow these
strategies if you follow a statistical
significant strategy and act like you're
sure okay
maybe not so horrible it's not
necessarily so bad
I mean you making decisions based on
random numbers like they're there there
are there are worse things to do like
maybe not doing anything at all you know
that that could be worse so like you
have to you have to evaluate these
things it's not enough to say like oh
how you're doing it wrong p-value ha ha
ha that's so stupid it might be fine
right you need to simulate the fake
world that's the only way you can do it
so as the saying goes to know the past
one must first know the future and so
the great Raymond Smolyan said that so
you know this because there's this field
called
experimental design and when you learn
statistics or data science whatever you
first learn now I'm on record as saying
statistics is the least important part
of data science which I think it's kind
of kind of correct that's that's another
story right I mean that actually so that
you learn it you data analysis first
right and then you learn design there
probably you never learned design
because they don't usually teach that so
it's kind of funny design comes first
you'd think you'd learn it first but you
can't really do a design unless you know
how you're gonna analyze the data you
just can't and and I mean you can make
stuff up but um so you know all of this
is why I now refuse to collect data
until I first simulated fake data I
think it's kind of immoral to do it like
I it's it's like you know buying a
product and you don't have a plan of how
to dispose of the waste sort of not
quite but um it turns out to a lot of
work so I'm actually involved in a
project with a colleague I I really
respect a lot and we've been stalled for
like a year because I haven't simulated
the fake data now I obviously it's not
my heart's priority I would have done it
but the point is I really mean that like
I don't think you should anymore do that
it's a it's very easy to just now
sometimes the data are already coming in
but in that case I feel like you should
allocate 10 percent of your effort to
simulating the fake date
and so forth that's Mike that's my
recommendation um so I wanted to tell
you a couple stories about how I feel
that multi-level modeling I feel as a
way of life a way of thinking about the
world partial pooling so first I'll tell
you one the stories of increasing length
first a very short story when I was
teaching statistical consulting many
years ago and the students were doing
the consulting and then they would come
in and meet with each other and the
instructor and we would talk about the
problem so some student came in and said
there was a was a problem it was a it
was some company doing research and
Silicon Valley is some like production
of chips or something like that and they
had data on 21 plants like factories and
they were fitting a regular client had
come in want to fit a regression model
and they had 16 predictors and 21 data
points so yeah there Derrell reaction
were like this but then another student
said hey you know I took this class last
semester he came in last semester and he
had 15 data points and 16 predictors and
I told him come back when you have more
data okay well wait a second can you
really learn enough I mean that's kind
of like what if I said you were 21 did I
tell this story in the previous okay I
can't remember well what what if I had
21 data points and one predictor without
be okay right
I mean you should all have issues where
the data came from about that will be
okay so all of a sudden 21 data points
and 16 predictors that's bad that's like
I wish I only had one day the one
predictor and so six how could more be
worse like that that makes no sense so
we had to kind of talk about a little
bit so you realize you can actually
learn something with 21 data points and
16 predictors
well maybe not by running them all
least-squares regression or even a
regular eyes regression but for one
thing you can make a scatterplot of each
outcome against one predictor at a time
and then it turns out that no single
predictor or predicts the outcome well
you didn't know that before right so
you've learned something these things
you can do right now we're more familiar
with this now like people do genetics
they have you know lots of predictors
but like there's something funny going
on about that story about like a
reaction how are we an instinctive
reaction is is so wrong so second was a
problem this was the for treatments five
dishes in six cultures problem so this
was another one from that consulting
class they say that you learn by
teaching right and it's it's true that
there was a biologist and they had four
they were doing something on little
critters that were living in little
cultures on dishes and there were I
don't remember what it was but there are
four different treatments and each
treatment was being applied to five
dishes so there are four treatments each
one applied to five dishes and within
each dish were six little cultures and
they came they had two possible analyses
and they wanted to figure out what to do
so the first analysis was so just to get
this clear there four treatments each
one had 30 data points so that and so
the first analysis is to say take the
average of all 30 basically treat them
as 30 independent data points before you
know so it's a problem you've you have
you have four treatments each one is 30
data points take the mean the standard
deviation go from there but then it's
like well they're kind of clustered on
dishes so maybe we should do is take for
each dish take the average and so then
you only have five data points for each
dish to use that like take the mean of
those five and the standard deviation of
those five as your data point what's but
then so then that seems Court of safer
to do the five right I mean it's not a
trick but it seemed safer to do the five
but then what if you
that it didn't really matter much like
the dish there were no dish of fact they
weren't interfering with each other in
the dishes then I should really do the
30 because it's six times more
information so they were really kind of
not sure what to do like they really
wanted to do the 30 but they're really
afraid of doing the wrong thing and so
they were kind of stuck so it turns out
in that case well you can talk about
with your neighbor for 30 seconds what
would you do
talk about your neighbor 30 seconds fine
what would you do
what now
yeah sure I'll take it
okay okay so yeah what to do it's like
wow although it depends on the day okay
it turns out there's a right answer here
and the right answer is to do the a5 not
the 30 and the reason is that it's true
that when you do the 5 you only have 5
but so it seems like your standard error
will be a lot higher but remember when
you do the 5 it's the standard error of
the 5 averages and if you think about
each one is an average so if it's truly
independent within dishes the average of
those 5 already has a 1 over square root
of the average of the 6 things within a
dish already it's like a 1 over square
root of 6 inside of it because it's an
average and so it turns out that if
there if there are dish effects you of
course want to do the 5 not the 30 but
if there are no dish effects then the 5
is really just reproduces the 30 no not
completely there's some issues of
degrees of freedom of estimating
variance but but pretty much that's the
right answer
so kind of interesting a little bit of
mathematical theory can can help us out
so that's one example now you tell you
another example and I'm going to loop
back talk about why multi-level modeling
is so great then I'm going to talk about
the pluralist dilemma I'm going to ask
why does it all matter and I'll tell you
why it all matters I'll tell you a funny
little thing and then I'll conclude the
talk so the next story is that Jay I
told him about the chick chick brains
did we do that last I'm not done we
haven't okay so in the 1980s some
epidemiologists discovered that kids who
live near
electric power lines were elevated risk
for leukemia and so there's a question
of how this could be and because
electric power lines they do radiation
they're alternating current Thomas
Edison said they were dangerous etc but
it's low energy it's low and it's too
low energy to ionize your cells and give
you cancer it's - it's not even like
microwaves that could can cook you it's
less than that so there was a theory if
they could affect you at all
it would be it could affect you through
brain functioning so your brain actually
communicates like with itself with these
you've maybe seen these brain waves like
roughly 60 Hertz
um cycles there's actual like electrical
action in your brain so the theory was
perhaps it would inhibit your body's
ability to fight cancer being near these
power lines that was the theory now just
to jump to the end it's been I think the
consensus now is that the correlation
between living near the power lines and
getting leukemia was not caused by the
power lines it's just other things that
children who live near power lines maybe
are also exposed to other to to actual
bad things but back in the 80s this was
not well understood so it was a valuable
kind of ally for science to drive down
to try to understand this so some some
researchers made an experiment where
they they killed some chickens and they
take the chicken brain and divide it in
two halves they measure the calcium
flowing out of the chicken brain so
apparently calcium channels are like a
thing okay and for each yeah I know I'm
trying to like talk like my kids you
know like I I was writing something the
other day and I actually like non
ironically use the phrase my dude which
is like what my kid says all the time
and it it really worked so you can you
can stay young I'm telling you it's
possible so we so they divided the
chicken brain into two parts measuring
the calcium efflux one half the chicken
brain is gets the control treatment
which is just whatever so sitting there
the other is in another room exposed to
low-frequency magnetic fields and they
did a series of thirty-eight experiments
starting at one Hertz then 15 Hertz 30
Hertz 45 stepping up every 15 Hertz
until 510 Hertz so at every frequency
they did an experiment with a bunch of
chickens and they had the exposed and
the control and you can take the
difference and estimate the effect of
the exposure on calcium efflux well
they did something else to be safe they
also did a sham experiment the exact
same except the whole thing was turned
off so like the exposed there was no
exposure and what they actually did was
they did treatment - control in the
exposed group and then they did
treatment - control in this sham group
and then took the difference between
them completely safe so they they did
this resolve they they they they got
some results kind of equivocal results
they found some statistically
significant patterns at different
frequencies more than you would expect
just by chance like taking their data at
face value there was something going on
um nothing going on in the Sham data
though if you look at the Sham data
they're completely consistent with zero
okay which by the way I'm doing a
hypothesis test it has its value here
that the zero is consistent with with
the data so here's a question there's
two possible analyses the one is the
safe analysis which is take treatment -
control subtract expose - control
subtract sham - control okay that's safe
just in case you're controlling okay if
there's some bias that snuck in you're
subtracting it the other and the other
analysis is just take exposed - control
throw out will Y throughout the Sham
because by subtracting sham well you're
doubling your variance right so it took
there's a cost to including that it's
similar to our other puzzle like what's
the right thing to do and we looked at
the data we took advantage of the fact
that there were 38 experiments so we
could see that there wasn't much going
on and there's no evidence for anything
going on in this sham so you have to
think like which would you do 30 seconds
with your neighbor what would you do
when you subtract the Sham or not
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay stop so okay so okay so I'll
tell you the answer okay the answer is
you should not use the Sham data you
should throw away the Sham data now I I
won't say you should act as if the Sham
data were never collected because the
Sham data contained the elements of
their own destruction it was only
through using seeing the Sham data right
so this is like you know you you have a
business and you hire two accountants
just to make sure nothing got messed up
they give you the same answer it doesn't
mean it was a mistake to hire two
accountants okay well maybe it was a
mistake for them to do 38 sham
experiments because if you read their
paper and then they a few years later
they were to follow a paper they said
that we were there was some uncertainty
in their results and they just didn't
have the budget to go further so in fact
if you look carefully at what they did
they doubled their cost now it doubled
their cost because they had fixed costs
but they doubled their variable costs
right they they could have gathered
twice as many data points for that and
then by including the Sham data they
doubled their variance right so they
paid twice for that and that that's
actually serious I mean then it's like
to the extent the experiment was worth
doing in the first place they were
really they they were hurting themselves
twice now but this the fact that I told
you these two stories is introductive I
could tell you more I don't know if I
have time to tell more stories but but
for these two is that superficially like
they very similar stories and the
superficial message is the opposite
right from the first story the messages
do the conservative thing it turns out
it's just as efficient the second one is
don't do the thing that looks
conservative it's throwing away
information now this is one of the
frustrating things about statistics to
students and I think those of you who do
like analytics real
this is confusing to people you talk
with is that the answer often seems to
depend on something technical and when
people try to kind of jump to the
solution it seems like they're often
like taking like they're often like
generalizing at the wrong point right
like you'd hear the first story and
you'd say well the message is you know
do the safe thing and then you're the
second story and it seems like a
different message so it's a it really is
a challenge and it's easy to get fooled
and when we teach it's like that like we
say oh this you really have to worry
about X Y & Z but then here I don't
worry about that that's you know this is
just a rule of thumb we can use it
people get confused when I was a student
my advisor in class told us that if you
have a randomized experiment it doesn't
matter if the people in the experiment
or a representative sample the
population because you have a randomized
experiment so you get kosher inference
for the treatment effect but that was
wrong if there's any treatment
interaction because if the treatment
interacts it's bigger for some people
than others than if you've estimated the
treatment effect in a Arella
in an irrelevant or non-representative
sample that can be a big problem right
so there's a lot of like there are these
principles it's very confusing so how do
I try to resolve these problems myself I
try to use multi-level modeling and
that's kind of the statistics or math
version of the simulate the world thing
that I told you earlier so in this case
let's do it in these these two examples
okay so first the the four treatments
with the five dishes and the six things
so I can set up a model and I can say
well let's start with an additive model
there's treatment effects there's dish
effects you work it through you see what
happens you tried if you can try
different estimators and you can doubt
when it's kind of easy to do you kind of
work it out and it turns out that that
the taking the average of the five for
each one is close to optimal now if
you're really careful if you do full
Bay's you stand
hmm then you do that and then you'd get
a little better because you can get a
better estimate of the variance
you can even model the variances varying
there's there's a little more there's a
little more than you get out of it but
not a lot you can see that by simulating
the fake world now in my second example
of the chickens well I need a lot here I
need okay so what's the model so the
model is that there are 38 effects that
I care about that's what I want to study
the effect at 1 Hertz the affected 15
the effect of 30 so forth that's what we
care about but then can you have to kind
of you have to kind of like
reverse-engineer what people did to
figure out what their model was right so
if these people were doing a sham
experiment assuming they're not like
let's give them credit for kind of
knowing what they're doing even if they
didn't analyze the data right and say
they were concerned there could be a
separate bias at each frequency because
if it was a constant bias you wouldn't
need to do 38 so we have to model we
have to model there being 38 treatment
effects and then 38 biases and then from
there it's not hard to come up with a
model where the the outcome for the sham
experiment is biased plus noise the
outcome for the treatment the exposed is
treatment effect plus bias plus noise
and then you see you take a difference
and the bias drops out and it's so
simple cool but you do find there's an
advanced your simplicity but you do the
full base thing and it turns out that
you can do partial pooling with the
amount having to do with how how
variable the the sham results are and
you can get a better answer so we can
work it out and figure it out so that's
kind of what we have to do that's how we
have to solve just like probability
problems the same way we have to solve
them by creating the fake world I don't
think there's any other way of doing it
now when I do that I'm putting myself on
the line right because you can come back
and say I don't believe your model okay
but that's fine I want that I don't want
to come up with a method and then you
say I don't believe your method I want
you to I'm gonna model and the example
III model and then we can do better so
you know I think getting back to all
those pvalue sometimes I think that if
all the
bozos would just stop using formal
statistics entirely that would be fine
with me just present your results I did
this study with 40 college students and
this is what I found
put me on NPR whatever get me a goddamn
Ted that's fine with me let's be on open
okay but why do it why bring in
statistics at all okay that's how I feel
but the funny thing is from their
perspective they just want to do their
science and make people make them do
this horrible statistics they make them
do that even though they don't want to
and and so I'll just conclude my talk
with this that we've got a ways to go
[Applause]
what we're gonna break the rule
especially for dr. Gellman will take
three questions time for three questions
all right who has a question can we get
the microphone actually can you grab the
microphone real quickly anyone have a
question now's your chance only
questions aloud the whole conference all
right there you go
microphones gonna be hard to get to you
let's grab this thank you for your
presentation so for example I want to
predict Sam Seng using many variables
and kind of I want to use the
hierarchical modeling because there is
no natural cluster with within my data
set but but now how I designed the
hierarchical model and how I can I do
the variable selection oh you can I mean
there there are different approaches but
I would I would throw all of your
variables into your model and then I
would partially pull them I would use
very information at the level of the
variables themselves so the simplest
thing to do would be if you have a bunch
of variables and some you think more
important than others then you can label
them it's like ones twos and threes and
then have prior variances that are
larger and the ones and smaller and the
twos and still smaller and the threes in
order to do more partial pooling for
that we also have techniques using leave
one out cross validation where you can
try to improve things in different ways
it's really hard to answer to just
answer in general I mean it's kind of
impossible
but let me say there is a principle in
statistics that the most important thing
about a statistical method is not
the most important thing is not how you
analyze the data but what data you
include and the most important thing
about statistical method is not what it
does with the data but to what extent it
allows you to include more information
thank you oh okay the mic read of here
wait it's just passive part thank you
very much
so you advised us to to simulate the
data and you also admit that it's very
very hard I agree I I just don't know
how to start with that I've tried and I
stare at a blank piece of paper and I
it's just it is hard
do you have any advice for a novice
trying to learn this maybe books or or
approaches or something that I could get
better at that skill set I would say
well you know we are like trying to
write books and all that with this
exactly I think we're we're only
gradually only recently if we realize
the importance of fake data simulations
so like we're putting some examples in
regression and other stories and things
like that but I would say in a given
example just start simple but I think
you the paradox is you need to start
simple but sometimes it's only through
the complexity that you'll you'll learn
things like the example of that I just
told you about with the chickens there's
38 experiments if you did it with just
one experiment you wouldn't be able to
get anywhere so it is it is some you
know like building a house like you have
you put up one wall at a time but the
walls don't hold up until they're all
there and the roof is there too so it's
it's kind of a little bit of a
commitment I'd say all right last one
guys can you guys make
so this is also about simulating the
data um if you're assuming a full
probability model when you're doing that
because that sounds like what you're
doing why not just take a straight full
Bayesian approach and if you're saying I
don't know what the probability
generating model is why not just do
something frequentist like a bootstrap
like what is the advantage of simulating
before if you really believe that this
is the true distribution
oh I don't I've never believed that the
true model at all so it's that's that's
an easy one so I would say that I will
set up a problem it's like I'll set up a
probability model that's kind of can
kind of reproduce something that seems
sort of close to reality and then once
that model is there I can try different
competing approaches but so it's I'm
crazy sorry yeah I was gonna say but how
do you know it's close to reality until
you have the data well you know I I
don't and even after I have the data I
don't really know but like it's often
there are just minimal things that you
need so like if the modeling like I said
that thing the modeling included.this
the experiments included sham treatments
so it makes sense to put that in or in
this like a be testing the very fact
that you have to say well how big are
the effects how fast are they coming in
like just asking the questions as often
I think the most valuable part of it and
yeah it won't be the most realistic
thing but I think it'll be a lot more
realistic than like trying to pull out
formulas from some book on bandits or
whatever all right with that thank you
very much
[Applause]